- Good morning Believe Nation.
Today we're going to talk
about, how to reinvent yourself.
Rule number one is my personal favorite,
and make sure to stick around
all the way to the end, for
some special bonus clips.
Also, as people are talking,
if they say something that
really, really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below,
and put quotes around it,
so other people can be inspired, as well.
Enjoy.
(upbeat music)
(bright music)
- You have to reinvent yourself.
If the person you are today,
is not allowing you to get
to where you want to get to,
you don't cry about it,
you don't whine about it,
you don't waste energy,
cuz you only have so much of it.
What you do is say,
I've got as much as I can get
with what I have.
I've got as far as I can go,
with who I am and who I currently am,
is not gon' take me to where I got to be.
So I got to reinvent myself.
So you say, Eric, what do you mean
when you say reinvent yourself?
I mean Michael Jordan.
That's right.
I know you thought Michael
Jordan won championships
his first year in the league,
maybe you thought he won
a championship in second.
But, no, no, no.
It took Mike, seven years, right.
Seven years to make that
dream become a reality.
So the first Mike,
yup, he put up a lot of points.
Yup, the first Mike,
he won a dunk contest, you're right.
Yup, the first Mike put up,
like 62 against Boston, in
the playoffs and still lost.
That's right.
The Michael Jordan I'm talkin' about
he had the fresh gym shoes,
the Nike Airs,
he had the t-shirts, right.
Everybody knew him.
But guess what, that Michael Jordan
didn't win any championships.
I'm going to say it again.
The Mike that could score 62,
the Mike that could dunk from half court,
the Mike that could wow
you in the All-Star game.
The Mike that we all loved.
That Michael Jordan didn't
win one championship.
And so guess what Mike had to do.
Mike had to reinvent himself.
And so what did he do?
Mike started playing both ways.
He just didn't play offense
no more, he played defense.
He didn't score a lot,
but he started to pass.
He started to work out a little different.
He developed not just a dunk,
but he developed a little 16 foot eject,
you know the little fade away.
And guess what?
The new Mike, ditched the old Mike.
He just said, well ya know what,
I'm puttin' up 62, I'm
gettin' discouraged.
You know what I'm sayin'.
I'm doin' all kinds of
shootin', I'm scorin',
I'm winnin' titles, I'm
winnin' championships.
No, no, no, no, no he didn't say that.
He says, I'm not able to do that,
because the man I am, is not takin'
me to that point, and so
I got to reinvent myself.
And so he didn't give up, he didn't quit.
He reinvented himself.
He started playin' defense, baby.
He started passin', baby.
He started shootin' instead of
just dunkin' and guess what?
He went from one, to two, to three,
to four, to five, to six championships.
And many of us believe,
had he not retired,
he probably would have won eight
titles, baby, that's right.
Diaper Dandy, baby.
Eight titles.
And so it's your boy ET sayin' number one,
you got to reinvent yourself,
right?
If you're not where you want to
be, don't quit, don't give up.
If you're not getting
the goals accomplished,
if you're not making your dream come--
don't quit, reinvent yourself.
- Entrepreneurs who have
authored a product or a process
that isn't working today,
have to make the bold step
of reinventing themselves.
I talk about it all the time.
How over the course of my life,
whether it was at 12 years old,
or 18 years old, or 25
years old, or even today.
I'm constantly working to reinvent myself.
I'm not any different
than a package on a shelf.
People have to feel that it's relevant.
They have to see the warning labels.
They have to understand the contents.
It has to be appealing.
It has to provide value to people.
And so when an entrepreneur has a product
or a process that they've authored,
and they're not willing to change it,
then they're going to
end up like Circuit City,
or Montgomery Ward,
or Sears, or Fiat.
Or whatever these brands are
that don't exist anymore, right?
Every single company
in this country today,
if they're not evolving,
they're dying.
And I don't know why an entrepreneur
would think that they would
be exempt from that process.
I'm not interested in their ego.
I'm not interested in their pride.
I'm not interested in their feelings.
I'm interested in their
business being successful.
And so, I think not only does
their business have to do it,
but we, as entrepreneurs
have to do it as well.
(bright techno music)
- The break through happens
by conditioning your mind every day,
by feeding it a role model, or story.
It's putting yourself in a peak state,
when you follow through, by
getting physically strong.
Its creating a little ritual,
of doing a little bit each
day, and then you get momentum.
But, the most important thing of all,
is what we start out with.
Why?
- Absolutely.
- Why is it a must for you?
It doesn't have to be
you're against the wall,
but it has to be something
you're hungry for.
Cuz the only difference
in people, is hunger.
And if you're not hungry,
get around people that are hungry,
and somethin' will hit you.
You'll watch a conversation,
you get around people
that are doin' better
and all of a sudden you start
goin', uh my life sucks.
I remember I went to a guy in LA
it's one of the most well,
multi-billionaire guy, I'll never forget.
And I lived in the Del Mar
Castle, and I was really proud.
That was like the symbol of me,
having taken myself from being poor
to providing for my
family, this great place.
It's built from castles in Europe
overlooking the ocean, not far from you.
And I went to this guy's
house, he's a billionaire.
He took me down to his wine cellar,
and I don't even drink wine.
Went through this whole thing,
at the end of the night I was depressed.
I lived in a Del Mar tenement,
as far as I was concerned.
I really was, I was like,
I live in a crappy place,
and all my standards changed.
All of a sudden I wasn't willin'
to settle for living there.
All of a sudden, my back was
to the wall in a different way,
because as a man, I knew
I was capable of more.
So people can change their standard
by gettin' around where it's better.
People can change their
standard by gettin' associated.
What's true like the
bills they got to solve,
the problems they got to do it.
Or they can do it because they're excited
cuz there's somethin'
new they want to take on.
Everyone's different, but
they got to find the why
and they got to come up with some
daily rituals to get 'em goin'.
And just do a step at a time.
That's where you get momentum.
- When I traveled across the country,
and I talked to basketball players, right?
When I talked to football players,
when I talked to baseball players, right?
This is what I tell these guys,
you are this close to goin' to the league
and makin' your dreams become a reality.
Do yourself a favor,
don't sabotage yourself.
Now dudes you got to
hear me, I'm tellin' you,
reinvent yourself, but
after you reinvent yourself,
I'm tellin' you, don't sabotage yourself.
What do you mean there?
I tell my boys, listen to me,
if you don't make it to the NBA,
let it be because you had an injury.
Not because you got kicked off the team
because academically you weren't
where you were supposed to be.
That's sabotaging yourself.
Right, don't sleep in, right?
When you supposed to be at prac--
that's sabotaging yourself.
Don't get a DUI, don't
get kicked off the team
because you've broken some school policy,
or some teeny poli--
that's sabotaging yourself.
If you get kicked off, let it
be because you put in 120%,
somebody was better than you.
Or somethin' happened to you physically,
and so you couldn't stay in the game.
But don't sabotage yourself.
You say, Eric, what d'ya mean?
Don't sabotage yourself, by
pushin' the snooze button.
Don't do it man.
When you tell yourself
you goin' wake up at five
o'clock in the mornin'.
You look at the clock
and it's five o clock,
don't sabotage yourself
by pushin' the snooze.
Don't sabotage yourself
by comin' to class late.
Don't sabotage, get there on time.
As a matter of fact, the
Vince Lombardi rule says
if you get there 10
minutes early, you on time.
If you get there on
time, you already late.
Don't sabotage your success.
When you get in there, put all your heart,
put all your mind, put all your soul.
And at the end of the day you put in 120
and you still didn't get a A,
you got a B, or you got a C.
At least you can walk away feeling good
knowin' that you put everything
you got on the table.
You put forth 120%.
So don't sabotage yourself
by hangin' out with the wrong people.
Remember, birds of a
feather flock together
and eagles and pigeons don't
hang out together, baby.
Alright, once again, it's your boy ET.
And remember, baby,
today is your day, man.
Today is the beginning
of a brand new life.
Today is the beginning of makin'
all your dreams become a reality.
And how do I know?
How do I know?
Cuz I started off as a
high school drop out.
I started as somebody who was homeless.
I started from the
bottom, and by God's grace
worked my way up to the top, baby.
So, if I can do it, you can do it.
But listen to me, you got to understand
that the only way through
storm, count on joy.
If you in the storm, count it joy.
If you comin' out of
the storm, count it joy.
Cuz it ain't about the
storm it's about your heart.
It's about your mind,
it's about your effort.
Everybody goes through storms.
Are you listenin' to me?
As ET was blowin' up, my mother-in-law
got diagnosed with terminal cancer,
and they told her she was supposed
to die last December
and she's still livin'.
My number one fan Susan Turner,
while I was blowin' up
on YouTube, she was dyin.
Are you hearin' what I'm sayin' to you?
Life happens, but when
the tough get goin',
when things get tough, man.
When things get tough,
the tough get goin'.
And I like my man Tim, Tim put it best.
Tim said, "When you goin'
through trials and tribulations,
"the best thing you can do is handle it.
"The worst thing you can do is panic.
"Use it to your advantage."
Why? Because if you've ever
studied that eagle, baby,
what you know about that eagle is
the eagle flies best when there's
storms when there's winds.
Because what does the eagle do?
It doesn't have to flap.
What it does is it uses the wind
from the storm to push it and elevate it.
And so, I'm here to tell you today, baby,
I don't care what your trials are,
what your tribulations are.
Elevates like that airplane.
Get beyond the clouds,
elevates.
Don't worry about your haters.
Your haters are like
pigeons and guess what?
Pigeons can only fly so high.
So you don't have to worry about people,
and circumstances, and situations.
You just fly to a place
that they can't go to.
You elevate yourself when you fly
to a place that nobody else can go to
but those who are
willing to be successful.
- My career, my entire career,
is a study in reinvention.
Ya know I started out as
a comedian, that was it.
I never planned on hosting a radio show,
hostin' a game show,
or hostin' a day time talk show.
I never did.
Writing books? None of it.
Making movies. None of it.
Reinvention happens, when
you diversify your gift.
There lies your greatest
secret for success.
You've got to discover your
gift and when you discover it
you got to soak it, you
got to wring it out, man.
You got to diversify it.
Most of us only have one talent.
But do you know that that's all you need?
Mine happens to be to take information
and immediately transfer it
into other kinds of platforms.
Now when I was younger, I actually thought
that I could only do that with comedy.
But as I've gotten older,
I discovered through diversification
that it was a little bit more than that.
That I could also take
information, immediately,
transfer it into inspiration.
I could turn it into motivation,
I can offer it as guidance.
So now sittin' on a talk show,
I actually have somethin' to talk about.
All the failed marriages.
I got somethin' to talk about.
The bein' homeless, I got
somethin' to talk about.
Bein' dead broke, I got
Havin' bad credit, tax problems,
I got somethin' to talk about.
Whatever hole you been in
I can just about drug myself through it.
But I came out of all of it because
I was not afraid
to diversify my gift.
Even the book, Act Like
a Lady Think Like a Man,
it was all about me diversifying a gift.
Okay, I had taken two failed marriages,
and I had taken the love for my daughters,
and I combined those things.
I taught my daughters,
what I knew about men.
Now little did I discover,
that I had a little over
four million daughters in this country.
Cousins and nieces and stuff like that
who needed that same information.
And that was a huge part for me,
to take that information
and turn it into a book
that turned it into a mega star movie.
And it produced a lot of things for me,
but it also helped a lot of people.
One of the other tricks
for reinventing yourself,
is not letting your background
become a limitation.
If you take that
background that you're from
and never let it define you,
but allow it to redefine you
all that stuff works for the good.
Do you understand that you needed
everything that's happened to you,
to happen to you in the exact
order that it's happened
in order for you to be the
person that you are today?
All that failin' and gettin'
over, you needed all of that.
(audience applauding)
So it's good to be steeped in
the traditions of your gift
but don't get stuck in 'em.
Look if your gift is baking,
don't assume that there's
only one way to do it.
If you bake, bake.
But you can't just bake
for people you know,
bake for people you don't know.
You're a musician, let yourself
explore other types of music.
I'll tell ya example, The Roots,
who play on Jimmy Fallon's show.
They steeped in hip-hop, but
they're also great musicians.
So what they do is, they take all
of that talent and now guess what?
Hip-hop, jazz, R&B,
classic, pop, rock.
They didn't just get stuck on hip,
I'm doin' hip-hop, that's it.
Nah, they do whatever.
LL Cool J. Hip-hop.
One of the top actors on TV today.
Queen Latifa, hip-hop, big
actor right now, ya get it?
Jerry Seinfeld, nothin' but a comedian,
one of the biggest actors on TV today.
Remember, you can win if you're
not afraid to reinvent yourself.
Stop gettin' stuck.
Just go ahead and give
it a try, ya never know.
- So how do we cultivate this
idea of kind of reinventing
but its more like, innovative
ideas for ourselves
to create something new.
How do we cultivate
these innovative ideas?
- Well let me ask you a question.
When you switched into, I don't know,
did you play handball
since you were a kid?
- [Lewis] No.
- Okay so how did you decide
I'm going to be an Olympic
level athlete in handball?
- Sure.
- and...
what was the first thing you did?
- I saw it on TV, I
watched the 2008 Olympics.
I was sleeping on my sister's couch still.
With the, I'd just gotten my cast off
from playing football, from a surgery.
And I watched some Olympics and it,
instantly I just had a new idea.
I said that's something I want to do.
I just like, I want to play on the USA.
- So, so something..
stirred inside you?
- [Lewis] Yes, yes.
- Like, you felt it.
- [Lewis] It was like a dream,
a new dream was created.
- And that happens to people,
I don't want to say every day,
but like, once a year,
a couple times a year,
once a month that you feel that
and you don't always
pursue everything, right?
- [Lewis] Right.
- I'm sure there's many
things you would like
to do that you don't pursue.
- Don't have the bandwidth for,
or it's not the right
timing or whatever, yeah.
- [James] But you already
had training as an athlete.
- Yes.
- So you knew okay this is another sport.
This is something where I hit, it's almost
like a back door to the Olympics because,
- [Lewis] Yes.
- or to the US team,
because who else would think to do this.
- [Lewis] No one else is playing, yeah...
- So, it seems like an old man
swearing I can probably squeeze
in here and get good enough.
Okay, so what'd you do next?
- So next, I started researching.
I went online and started
researching like USA handball,
handball teams in Ohio,
there was nothing in Ohio.
Then I said okay where are
the teams in the country?
And then I started looking at
like what are the best teams?
cuz if I'm going to learn this quickly,
I need to learn from the best.
So I learned that the New York team,
had won the national championships
over the last few years.
So I was like okay when
I make enough money,
I'm going to go to New
York City and learn from
these players, this team.
And for about the next year,
I was like well how am I going to do that?
Cuz I have no money, I'm
broke on my sister's couch.
That's when LinkedIn started
kind of opening up for me.
And I started to make,
like a few hundred bucks
a month teaching LinkedIn.
So I said, okay, when I make
enough money doing this,
then I'm going to leave Ohio
and go to New York City.
To like, see what this is like.
- And by the way, when
you were in New York City,
it's not like you stopped
making money on LinkedIn.
- [Lewis] No, no, I was still doing that.
- These things are
interweaving each other.
- They're all interweaving, yes.
So I about a year later,
a year and a half later,
I started really making a lot of money
like just kind of started happening.
Everything started to unfold and happen
after a lot of action taking.
And so I moved to New
York City for a month.
Now at the whole time for
this year, year and a half,
no one would respond to me on
the USA national team for
like the headquarters.
No one would respond to
me at the New York team.
I would email people,
I would call numbers,
no one would get back to me.
- How were you getting
better during this time?
- I was just training as an athlete,
but I still hadn't played handball yet.
But I still had this idea of like,
I need to go and at least explore it,
so I don't regret not trying
to see if I could make this.
I was like at least I got to go and try it
so I can kind of eliminate it from my mind
as something I want to do or I
don't want to do in the future.
But for me personally, I know that if
I think about something, I want to do it
and if I don't at least explore it
I'll think about it
for the rest of my life
and I'll regret not trying.
Not giving it a go.
- Right
- So I said okay, no one's
getting back to me anywhere.
I'm emailing people every month.
I'm trying to call people every month,
no one's getting back to me.
So I say screw it, I'm going
to go to New York for a month.
I had a couple of
speaking gigs in New York
for like LinkedIn something,
and had some social media conferences.
And I was like, I'm just
going to go stay for the month
and I'm going to show
up at their practice.
Cuz they had the practice address
of where they practice on the
website for the New York team.
- So you got ready.
- [Lewis] I got ready.
- By constantly training.
- Training, yep.
- And then you just you fired.
- That's it, I just showed up.
And I showed up at practice
when they said they were playing,
cuz no one picked up or got back to me.
- [James] No one gave you
permission to do that.
- No one gave me permission.
I showed up and the first day I got there,
I was the only American
on, who was in the court.
And it was all these
former professional players
in Europe, who now moved to
New York and kind of like,
live and play for fun.
- So as a white man.
- Yes.
- You were basically the minority
on the American team.
- I was the minority.
I was like-- they barely spoke English.
I was just like this outsider.
And I got there and I go,
hey guys, my name's Lewis,
I'm here from Ohio
and my goal is to make the Olympics
and play with the USA national team.
And they just all started laughing.
And then I just showed
up every single week.
I ended up moving there, to New York.
I didn't go back to
Ohio, I stayed there for
the next year and a half.
And nine months later I made the USA team.
But I was there every
single week practicing
and just like learning
and taking action and--
- So what you did was,
exemplifies something that I,
and this isn't original to me
I'll describe where it comes from
but I call, in my book, I call this,
you reinvent yourself by
finding your plus-minus-equal.
So your plus was all these people,
you wanted to be around
the best in the world
- [Lewis] People better than me.
- Right so you could learn from them.
So you have to find your plus.
And at first they're virtual.
You maybe watch YouTube videos about them,
you read books about them.
You study things that they
write, or photographs they take
or videos they shoot.
So then they became real for you because
you actually joined them and
started hanging around them.
Then you have to find your equals.
Because if you're just crushed every day
in a game of handball, it's
going to be hard for you.
You need lessons, but then you need
people who challenge you.
- [Lewis] Yes.
- So people who you can say ugh, I got
that one more point off
him, I feel challenged.
Then you get better and better,
and you can measure your results.
- And there were people
there that were like that,
who on the team were kind
of beginners so I was--
- Right. So you found your peer group.
- Right
- You found...
your new cohort.
And then you find kind of,
its almost a bad word for it,
but you call it, I call it the minus.
Which is people you could teach.
I don't know if this was like,
a catalyst for your reinvention.
But ultimately, you
play people in handball,
that you're a lot better than.
Then you could teach them and
that solidifies your learning.
- [Lewis] Right.
- So and that's almost every reinvention,
ya know you and I have both had
hundreds of people on our podcasts
they've all reinvented themselves.
And I bet you in every single case,
there's a plus-minus-equal.
- [Lewis] Yeah, I'm sure.
- So that happens with all of
'em, like I talk to anybody
from a rapper, to a huge entrepreneur,
like a billionaire entrepreneur.
They've all had their plus-minus-equal.
- What are some of the steps
that you guide people through
of how they can reinvent themselves?
- Well again, everybody wants
the sort of quick, magic pill
and I think in the time that
we've got available here,
what I really want to do is guide people
into some areas of focus that
can really add some value.
And the first one that I always pick,
is about asking better questions.
Yeah, questions direct our focus.
And if you're not direct
in your own focus,
I've got news for you,
there's a lot of people
that pay a lot of good
money to Madison Avenue
to ya know figure out
how to do it for you.
- Right.
- And, that's not the life we want to live
being programmed by
other people's agendas.
And I liken the mind to a compass needle.
It can only point in
one direction at a time.
And the challenge is just like if
we take a needle and magnetize
it, like back in high school.
You take a magnet, a power
source and you align it
and keep stroking that needle
in one continuous direction
so that needle aligns
to the magnetic field.
And becomes coherent pointed
now all of the ions
point in one direction,
it becomes magnetized.
Now our mind is very similar.
Now if we are open to
unconsciously being programmed,
which unfortunately as human beings,
we are you know we're a 24/7
constant adaptation machine.
Now our mind and our body,
Now we understand the
body part that's easy
now the physical side
of life everybody gets
because they have
experiential, now evidence of.
Now your body will adapt if
you put it in McDonald's,
or if you put it in the gym.
It doesn't mind, it will adapt
accordingly, that's its job.
But our mind is far more programmable,
far quicker than our body.
And if the magnet
that the strong force
that's constantly magnetizing us,
is usually the media and our peer group.
And if those two aren't optimal
then ya know were going to
be sucked along for the ride
and don't really magnetize
our true north for ourselves.
So by asking better questions,
what it does it shifts the
direction of that needle.
Now the challenge is, you
can only do that for 10%
of the time that you're conscious,
or sleeping awake is how most
people are 90% of the time.
You ask why when we're driving to work
we can't remember the last
two kilometers on the freeway,
you know, what happened? (laughs)
But, now if we focus on
being able to magnetize
or take charge of which direction
our compass needle is pointing,
we have a chance to start
reinventing ourselves.
Because otherwise yeah again,
you're going to be drifting,
especially in that 90% of the time when we
do things out of habit, unconsciously.
That compass needle drifts back
to it's preconditioned magnetic north.
And most the time that doesn't serve us.
Whether it's media conditioned,
paper conditioned, and you
know society conditioned.
You know, look out of your window,
there's not many examples of
who we want to emulate and become
that surround us on a day-to-day basis.
So ya know the first question is,
or the first step is ask better questions.
Yeah, and what ignites you?
What causes you to come from a place of
wanting to really give your gift,
not survive in today's world,
cuz you got a mortgage to make.
Not take the path of certainty
which if the entrepreneurs,
if they haven't figured it out yet is,
I'm sure you'll let them know as well,
that there is no certainty in life.
Now so the ability to handle uncertainty
is one of the core characteristics
of an entrepreneur.
And so to be able to do that
ask yourself better questions.
Now what resources do I
have that I'm not using yet?
Great question cuz it'll start
you looking in different areas.
This is one of the best
things about the human brain
is if you ask a question
it'll give you the answer.
The challenge is that most
of us ask lousy questions.
Yeah, why's this always happen to me?
And it'll give you an answer.
It's programmed to, right?
Because you're worthless,
because you deserve it,
because you're not smart enough and all...
So by asking better questions,
we can search for better answers,
and that's really the
first place to start.
- I love it.
Is there a series of questions
that you recommend
everybody ask themselves?
Kind of regardless of their situation?
So that what ignites me,
what gives me passion,
what resources do I have
that I'm not currently using
are some that you mentioned.
Are there others that you recommend people
kind of get into the habit
of asking themselves?
- Yes, and it really ties
into what our call really
the next part of gettng into
reinventing who you are.
And that is to check your why.
Ya know we're driven by
reasons as human beings.
Yeah everybody does things for reasons.
Now they may not be your
reasons, may not be my reasons,
but yet we do things for reasons.
Most of the time unfortunately,
we do very little out of logical reasons.
Now we do a fair amount out of passion,
but most of what we do we do out of habit.
And those habits are formed
based upon the repetitive
questions we tend to ask ourself
which usually are sub-optimum.
So if you were to ask questions that
elicited your reason why.
And here's what I found
in the three decades
of being an entrepreneur now.
That is almost universally consistent,
if your why is focused
on you are not powerful,
you're not present, you
don't have the ability
to dig deeper than you could.
Unless it was rather than if your why
is focused on something greater than you.
And yeah we can see this
in evidence everywhere.
I'll give a classic example.
You take the New York
or the Boston marathon,
Boston gets more pros, but
the New York marathon's a goal
for a lot of people in their
fitness sort of resolutions.
And for those that haven't ran
a marathon before its a big goal.
It takes a lot of
training ya know I've ran
crazy stuff before and its not easy
if you're not a professional athlete.
So if you take New York, 35,000
people lining the streets
cheering you on, the
amount of people that run
the New York marathon for the first time
not the people who do it for fun,
or as an athlete on a regular
basis, but for the first time.
There is way more percentage
of those people that complete
the marathon that are
running for something else.
Not themselves, not
their ego, not the medal,
not significance, not the bragging rights.
To support somebody they loved,
in memory of somebody they cared about,
to raise money for a
cause they believe in,
something beyond themselves.
And that's because those that
are running for themselves
most of those quit before
the day of the marathon.
It takes a lot to dig deep when you're
just looking at going out of ego.
So questions that ask you
to reevaluate your why.
And most people's why, by default,
is grounded in a
an area that's really
is fear driven.
What if I fail?
Therefore my why for doing this because
I think it's going to give me
the best chance of success.
Not because I'm passionate about it,
not because it's giving
my gift to the world,
not because it's something
I've always wanted to do.
So asking questions like if I knew
it was impossible to fail,
what would I do then?
That removed the fear of failure away
and opened up possibility thinking.
And what it'll do it'll start
getting you in touch with
what inspires you, what lights you up,
what gives you that lift,
not the motivational factor
which is usually avoiding pain.
And needs a will power to get you through
getting up at 5 a.m. when its cold.
Inspiration you don't need motivation.
Motivation is a fuel tank in a car,
it runs out, it needs topping up.
Inspiration is a deeper well spring.
Now asking questions, like if I could only
spend my life doing one
thing, what would it be?
And start tuning yourself
in to that passion center
that a lot of the time we build
bars around to imprison it
through not having to face
the possibility of failure
and therefore admit to
ourselves we're not enough.
Which is usually what I see
with so many entrepreneurs
that are burning themselves out.
They're running patterns of
chasing things that they think
will give them the success that
will validate them in the eyes of others.
Whether it's their parents,
their business studies teacher,
their elder brother who they perceive
they're always trying
to be in the shadow of.
It doesn't matter, we've
all got our reasons.
Whereas if your independence of
what I call swimming in goop
G-O-O-P the good opinion of other people.
Most people spend their
life swimming in goop,
and its a sticky, nasty
smelly mess that will lead you
to a fast track to mediocrity and nowhere.
So if you can escape the
good opinion of other people,
and stand proud in your truth,
that win, lose or draw
I'm not taking it with me.
Ya know the only people that
tried that were the Egyptians.
And what happened?
3000 years later we
dug it up and stole it.
Ya know I'm here to make
the time I've got count.
I'm here to make a difference,
I'm here to give my gift.
And you can only do that
with the freedom of being
independent of the fear
of not being enough,
or the fear of having to
adapt myself consistently
like a chameleon to fit the
pictures of what I think other
people should see me as,
rather than say listen
yeah, I respect where you're
at, were always going to see
things differently because that's
who we are as human beings.
I'm celebrating my truth
and I'm walking this way,
and no one's talking me out of it.
I'm providing that nobody is less than
because you crossed their path.
You know there's a moral basis to that.
Then yeah swing the bat with a smile,
and strike out or hit a
home run but swing the bat.
- So my quick take on reinventing yourself
is that it needs to be a constant.
This isn't just one thing
that every now and then,
you reinvent yourself.
You are constantly evolving
and changing as a human being.
And the things that you
do, what's scheduled
into your calendar on a day-to-day basis,
needs to change and evolve
as you change and evolve.
I am a extremely rigid, scheduled person.
If you look at my calendar,
it's packed full of stuff
that I have to do every single week,
and I love that schedule.
But at the same time I'm
very hyper-focused and aware
of where I feel like
things are out of whack.
If I feel like I need to spend more time
on my YouTtube channel, I'm
being pulled in that direction.
Or I need to spend more time with my wife,
I'm being puled over here.
Or I need to spend more
time at TorontoDanceSalsa,
and I'm pulled this way.
or I need to spend more time as a father,
and I'm pulled that way.
I'm constantly analyzing, and
adjusting and then changing.
Making modifications in the
schedule to support what I'm
currently feeling, and
I think too many people,
your schedule is out of
whack with your priorities.
Maybe when you first set up your schedule,
maybe when you first set up your business,
everything was in alignment.
Here's what I want to
do, here are my goals,
here's what's important to
me, here's my priorities.
Okay great, I'm going to create a schedule
that's going to focus my efforts
on achieving those goals.
Amazing, as your priorities
change, as life happens to you,
you need to adjust your
schedule accordingly,
or you're going to be unhappy,
you're going to be dissatisfied,
you're going to constantly be
feeling a pull to go over here,
but you feel stuck here.
And as long as you feel stuck here,
you're never going to be happy.
And too many people are too
afraid to then make that change.
As an entrepreneur, you have the
ultimate freedom to be able to create
the schedule that you want.
And if you're not an entrepreneur yet,
stop blaming other people.
It's not your boss's fault that you
can't do what you want,
it's not your parents' fault
or your wife or husband's fault.
It's not your kids fault,
it's not your friend's fault.
It's nobody's fault, it's your fault.
You're not doing the
thing that you want to do,
it's nobody else's fault but yourself.
Own it, accept it and
start making some changes.
As soon as you feel like
you're being pulled somewhere,
that you want to go try this thing out.
That it's calling to you, then you need
to make an adjustment in your
schedule to allow for it.
Even if it's a temporary thing,
maybe it's to learn salsa dancing.
Maybe you go and you have a great time
at that first class and
you want to keep doin' it.
Maybe you take that first class
and you say, you know
what, that's not for me,
and you pull back, that's okay.
What's not okay is the regret.
What's not okay is continuing to think
of this idea that you
have, continue to wish
you had more time to spend on this thing
that's way over here,
and you stay stuck here.
Because until you find out,
you're going to constantly live in regret.
And it's going to get worse,
and worse, and worse, and worse.
The more that you want
this, and you're stuck here
it's going to get worse.
You're going to get increasingly unhappy.
And so for me, it's not
about getting so unhappy
that you have to make this huge change,
it's constantly adjusting what you do.
Constantly adjusting your priorities,
constantly adjusting your schedule.
And I strongly encourage you guys to
whenever you feel like
something is out of whack,
on the business side,
on the personal side,
on the development side, whatever it is.
You feel like you're being pulled
to do something else other than
what you're doing right now,
find a time to adjust your
schedule and make it happen.
It's on you to do it.
Nobody's coming to save you.
This is your responsibility,
to live your life,
to be the best version of you.
And that happens when you
follow that intuition.
And you find out, because
finding out and getting
the no, and getting a failure,
and getting you know
understand that's not for you.
Finding out is way better
than never finding out.
Finding out and losing is way
better than never finding out.
So do it.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Jude Silvera asked me to.
So if there's a topic
you'd like me to cover
in the next edition of BelieveLife,
please leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'm also super curious to find out
what of the clips resonated
the most with you?
What did you learn today that you're
going to immediately apply to
your life or to your business?
Please leave it in the comments below,
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I want to give a
quick shout out to Torsten.
Torsten, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word.
IT really, really,
really means a lot to me.
I love seeing that picture
of you holding it up.
So thank you for posting it.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you'll continue
to believe in yourself.
An whatever your one word is,
much love, have an amazing
day and I'll see you soon.
- My question, how can I go about
projecting myself as a writer
first and a teacher second?
What business steps can I take
to make this transformation?
Thank you for all you do, Christina.
Alright, so Christina, we got
some good answers for you today.
There's actually three very
simple, very effective things
that you can do right now
to make that transformation,
and make it happen fast.
The first one is speak it.
So words have tremendous
power, all you got to do
next time you find yourself
at a cocktail party,
just say you're a writer first.
So anytime you introduce
yourself talk about writing,
talk about your books,
talk about everything else
before you start saying you're a teacher,
and that's going to
make a huge difference.
So what we like to say
is justdoit, juss doeht,
juzdooet, Christina.
Number two, number two,
you want to write it
so all language that
goes out into the world.
Think about this, what does
your email signature say?
What does your business card say?
What about any social media profiles?
The very first thing
that you should have is
ding, ding, ding
writer, so if you don't
have writer as the first
thing listed on all of
your written paraphernalia.
Go and make that change
right now, I'll wait.
Do it? Didja jussdooit? Okay good.
Number three and this
is the most important
one of all is be it.
You have to write as much as you can.
So if you don't have a
blog I would highly suggest
you start blogging, perhaps journaling 'll
be more your thing, but
just really be the writer
that you actually are.
And it becomes pretty simple if you're
doing something habitually,
you're writing every day,
you're putting out blog posts,
you're publishing more books.
Naturally it's going to be the first thing
that pops out of your mouth.
- Do you think people are
screwed if they don't start
thinking about how they're
going to reinvent themselves?
- I think so because I
think ya know Kevin Kelly
who is,
he's got a great blog, I've
known him for a long time.
He has this great quote, and he's a
founding editor of Wired magazine.
He has this great quote,
"Productivity is for robots."
So what that means is it's
not about like rushin' around
being as productive as
possible, 20 hours a day.
And some people say that,
that you have to like
work, work, work, work,
work and then you know
reap the benefits later.
What he's really saying with
productivity is for robots,
is that everything that is
not about you learning personally
is going to eventually be
outsourced or automated.
And so you kind of have to create
your own have your own ideas
about what you want to be
and what you want to do.
And then you know work to create it,
and then eventually either
outsource it or move on.
So Foreston Ferriss talks about this
in the four-hour work week
where eventually he started
to automate his processes,
so he moved his work week down
from 80 hours to four hours.
That was the premise of that book,
but I think it's more
happening on a corporate level,
on a Fortune 500 level where
entire layers of middle management
and middle employees and even the workers
working at the factory,
that's all being automated
or moved to another country.
What's going to happen
when self-driving cars
are driving everybody around?
It's 90% of the auto industry
is just going to disappear,
and it's not like they're just going to
be transferred into the
self-driving industry,
that's going to be a smaller industry.
- They're going to have
to reinvent themselves.
That's just one industry.
Same thing's happening in
publishing, in the music industry,
in accounting, in the
legal industry, I mean..
- There's new software coming
out that makes everything
simpler for accounting,
you don't even ya know.
- Yeah, and also let's say you
and I were doing a contract.
We're going to be partners
in some new business.
I don't need a lawyer
I'll go to legalzoom.com,
download s document
and then we'll sign it.
And so many things are happening now,
and companies are catching up,
individuals are catching up,
and you know hopefully the
listeners are catching up.